mailand italien vor der korona pandemie
beliebtes urlaubsziel der deutschen
jetzt gibt es hoffnungen dass es die
deutsche vita bald wieder in der
italienischen millionenmetropole zu
erleben gibt endlich konnten bars und
restaurants wieder öffnen unsere
reporterin kira ortmann hat das leben in
mailand schon ein wenig genossen
oktober endlich wieder in einem
restaurant und dafür jetzt auch noch so
gutes italienisches essen essen es ist
ein bisschen ein komisches gefühl gerade
wenn man hier sieht die tische direkt
neben einen werden auch belegt und
natürlich beim essen und beim trinken
trägt keiner mehr eine maske allerdings
haben wir gerade schon mit vielen
italienern gesprochen wie gesagt haben
aber sobald sie aufstehen setzen sie die
maske auch dann halten sie sich wieder
genau an die regeln und darauf vertrauen
die läden dürfen wieder öffnen weil die
regierung viele regionen des landes auf
die gelbe zone heruntergestuft hat in
der die ansteckungsgefahr als gering
gilt es ist allerdings nicht erlaubt
sich zwischen den unterschiedlichen
regionen zu bewegen
die ausgangssperre von 22 bis 5 uhr
morgens bleibt in kraft dennoch sind die
lockerungen ein anlass zur freude
wir wollen das leben feiern mit alkohol
und pasta in italien sind die korona
neuinfektionen zuletzt deutlich
zurückgegangen dennoch liegt der
inzidenz wird noch über dem bei uns in
deutschland zwar waren die regierung das
weiterhin größte vorsicht walten muss
aber die freude über die wiedereröffnung
überwiegt
ich bin so glücklich denn italien ohne
restaurants ist wirklich traurig die
überraschenden lockerungen der korona
maßnahmen sind vor allem für
restaurantbesitzer immens wichtig ich
bin sehr glücklich dass wir wieder
eröffnen und wieder mit unseren
lieferanten und partnern arbeiten dürfen
aber ich wiederhole ich wünsche mir dass
wir ab jetzt regelmäßig arbeiten dürfen
weil wir nur mit kontinuität der arbeit
diese krise überleben werde
es bleibt zu hoffen dass es nicht
nochmal zu einer unkontrollierbaren
ausbreitung des corona virus in italien
kommt und die maßnahmen dann wieder
verschärft werden müssen
[Musik]